wie schaut's aus du kannst schon wissen
was das hq angeben also generell free
running back uhr trampolin breakdance
alles ein bisschen selber macht flecken
seit fünf jahren trampolin auch
irgendwie schon immer
also wir hatten immer ein trampolin im
garten und irgendwie geil konstatieren
den nerv sogar ohne scheiß ich mir jetzt
einspringen
kann ich auch ich bin die schnitzelgrube
okay ich hab heute zu probieren
damit musst du aber auch dann mache ich
richtig gas aus
dafür wirst du bezahlen mit den nerven
ich bin so tot war und wie lange waren
jetzt hier 34 10.000 stunden lang aber
ich will nicht alles geschafft
wir müssen was hast du noch mal
vorgenommen den doppelten franz liszt ja
genau und ich muss den weg gemacht ja
wir gehen nicht bevor wir es nicht
geschafft haben viel wichtiger gut ich
hab ja okay machen wir einmal noch
ja
und das nächste mal bei action haus